As promised, we will now start
developing generalizations of
the different calculations that
we carried out in the
context of the radar example.
The first kind of calculation
that we carried out goes under
the name of the multiplication
rule.
And it goes as follows.
Our starting point is the
definition of conditional
probabilities.
The conditional probability of
A given another event, B, is
the probability that both events
have occurred divided
by the probability of the
conditioning event.
We now take the denominator term
and send it to the other
side of this equality to obtain
this relation, which we
can interpret as follows.
The probability that two events
occur is equal to the
probability that a first event
occurs, event B in this case,
times the conditional
probability that the second
event, event A, occurs, given
that event B has occurred.
Now, out of the two events, A
and B, we're of course free to
choose which one we call the
first event and which one we
call the second event.
So the probability of the two
events happening is also equal
to an expression of this form,
the probability that A occurs
times the conditional
probability that B occurs,
given that A has occurred.
We used this formula in the
context of a tree diagram.
And we used it to calculate the
probability of a leaf of
this tree by multiplying the
probability of taking this
branch, the probability that A
occurs, times the conditional
probability of taking this
branch, the probability that
event B also occurs given that
event A has occurred.
How do we generalize
this calculation?
Consider a situation in which
the experiment has an
additional third stage that has
to do with another event,
C, that may or may not occur.
For example, if we have arrived
here, A and B have
both occurred.
And then C also occurs, then we
reach this particular leaf
of the tree.
Or there could be
other scenarios.
For example, it could be the
case that A did not occur.
Then event B occurred, and
finally, event C did not
occur, in which case we end up
at this particular leaf.
What is the probability of
this scenario happening?
Let us try to do a calculation
similar to the one that we
used for the case
of two events.
However, we need to deal
here with three events.
What should we do?
Well, we look at the
intersection of these three
events and think of it as the
intersection of a composite
event, A complement intersection
B, then
intersected with the
event C complement.
Clearly, you can form the
intersection of three events
by first taking the intersection
of two of them
and then intersecting
with a third.
After we group things this way,
we're dealing with the
probability of two events
happening, this composite
event and this ordinary event.
And the probability of two
events happening is equal to
the probability that the first
event happens, and then the
probability that the second
event happens, given that the
first one has happened.
Can we simplify this
even further?
Yes.
The first term is
the probability
of two events happening.
So it can be simplified further
as the probability
that A complement occurs times
the conditional probability
that B occurs, given that A
complement has occurred.
And then we carry over
the last term
exactly the way it is.
The conclusion is that we can
calculate the probability of
this leaf by multiplying the
probability of the first
branch times the conditional
probability of the second
branch, given that the first
branch was taken, and then
finally multiply with the
probability of the third
branch, which is the probability
that C complement
occurs, given that A
complement and B
have already occurred.
In other words, we can calculate
the probability of a
leaf by just multiplying the
probabilities of the different
branches involved and where we
use conditional probabilities
for the intermediate branches.
At this point, you can use your
imagination to see that
such a formula should also be
valid for the case of more
than three events.
The probability that a bunch of
events all occur should be
the probability of the first
event times a number of
factors, each corresponding
to a branch in a
tree of this kind.
In particular, the probability
that events A1, A2, up to An
all occur is going to be the
probability that the first
event occurs times a product of
conditional probabilities
that the i-th event occurs,
given that all of the previous
events have already occurred.
And we obtain a term of this
kind for every event, Ai,
after the first one, so this
product ranges from 2 up to n.
And this is the most general
version of the multiplication
rule and allows you to calculate
the probability of
several events happening by
multiplying probabilities and
conditional probabilities.